la même routine chaque jour depuis une
semaine
hamid et son collègue prépare les sacs
remplis de matériel de couture qui vont
être distribués aux bénévoles
voilà donc on met des élastiques le
tissu donc de lettres de bobines de fil
et on leur met également la petite
notice voilà et donc les consignes pour
amener les
les sacs aux mairies ils sont 200
couturiers et couturières à avoir
répondu à l'appel de la mairie de
vénissieux
parmi eux marie qui vient chercher son
sac de fournitures sa fête du travail
c'est à dire qu'il faut tout faire il
faut laver repasser coupé assemblée et
puis poser des caoutchoucs aux patients
nouveau voilà je suivais très fiers de
participer à ce projet c'est une
opération de solidarité de citoyenneté
les consignes de fabrication sont très
strictes et respecter les normes de
sécurité établies par l'afnor
l'association française de normalisation
face à la pénurie de masques pour
équiper ses agents la municipalité a
décidé de recourir au système d avec
l'objectif de fabriquer mille masques ça
répondait aussi un besoin un besoin de
masques et un besoin aussi pour pour les
habitants de sang qui rutile de sentir
concerné dans une chaîne et c'est ça qui
est important
même si certaines sont pas forcément des
couturières ou couturier aguerris ils
ont l'impression de faire partie d'une
chaîne de solidarité et et du coup ça
valorise une fois cousu les masques sont
lavés à 60 degrés puis rapporté à la
mairie qui s'occupe ensuite de la
distribution ils sont aussi destinées
aux bénévoles d'associations comme le
secours populaire la croix-rouge ou le
secours catholique sur le modèle de
vénissieux d'autres communes de la
métropole lyonnaise lance aussi des
initiatives similaires